Tell you know about it around a
strange thing that happened.
Carry am i the re left your
you can we went to g guy
and we played in the new bananas
and neighborhood heroin.
I'm telling him about how it
happened but the other 10.
The other owners of the lane wouldn't
sign eruption. He said he said.
Life is a way of taking care of itself
because something might happen to them to
this and i might lose a child or
brother and sister might die.
And i thought that was
rather strange thing to say
but i me a very short time
after runnable children like
this brink and was i
know my way was killed
and about five years later one
of her brothers died of cancer.
And i thought i had when i was a coincident
with them and. That is really true.
Bring on tell me about your
wedding day. Well the moral.
But we need a house that wasn't painted
and we were going to have the reception
or not actually the reception
the reception was held in town
but later we were going to go to work to
home to my place of course very thought
i'd describe all the laws
down with hot water inside so
that everything was shown in plain sight.
I'm awaiting that mother it was that
cried you that he now live. But anyway.
Great all that money and light a
long right prop for me nicely.
We've got married at the cathedral
on the 9th of october 1944.
Then after that we went to a boarding
house not a mrs. no he had reached st..
And she gave us the reception there.
But of course you couldn't stay there
for too long and in those days.
The customer just started up on night
and didn't go home so
we went on to my place
and home of course we had a lot more
things to read and everything out there.
Dear do you remember who know you it
with the prayer the praise from the
girl and god because we were
in his parish bad about. Here.
So we didn't go home till the
next day and the next day
when you didn't have a utility or anything
so my brother in law took me home
and you hear about all that happened and.
What kind of civilities did
you have at the rating
or were kind of here's a guy we had
and yes we had mr. morality
and i forget his name now.
He played little him beautifully involved
it's going to sydney made a living.
Deal directly played the more i mean he
also played beautifully not he have since
died. Yes and it was dancing we had a
veranda so we had everything set up
and then marina and food in.
That your family your mother and your
family prepared here in back here by day
but but actually the running back was
right in town when we went to miss it.
And i think it was sort of a carry on
because it was raining but this was it.
Lunch time we got married in the morning.
That was all the custom in any writing and
then sort of you went on to the night
and the night we had a meal and then you
were up on. Right now it will be no party.
Can you know. How on earth where you are
a bit exhausted after our surprise you.
Were but. Everybody did
that you know you know sort of
it may not do what you know
but gradually all that's come to now
and younger generation
cannot actually i think
when you get a great
military gotten our time
and you don't have to rewin if you
don't want to danger one for a lot
but first coming at my
kids get older i think.
I think some of the bigger
ratings are getting to be.
And you can meet everybody
and that i think
that is one of the reasons why i don't
mind such an enjoyment in a big wedding
years and the other end of the sky
where it's so expensive. T.j.
To me to do anything that's
right. The ratings at home.
I think been four months of flight.
But that's just what kind of station
my. What kind of food. Did you.
Did you prepare for the morning breakfast
would have been a four course meal you
would have started with on try which was
probably salami and quarter of an egg
and a slice is a matter of
like a cucumber slice of ham.
Weapon or less young try
but you went on to say chicken soup which
you know you know then you went on to
broach it which was with.
More vegetables sort of mashed potatoes
and pumpkins and things like that
when you had your roast chicken
which went with back the taliban.
And i think they had lettuce
with it whatever baggage double
and then you had your swedes.
And.
Brain about brought libya to australia where
rights again he was the eldest of the
family. And it was not actually
expected but merely because
that wasn't enough for everybody
to live on love a lot
and the older men of the time you might
try to twist drag canada a lot of other
places thoroughly define the word lucky
inasmuch as he's had his uncle jack parent
here and he came out and virtually
all he would work for different.
Families. He got a pound a
week and tobacco and balls
that i used to pay my way by and i had
to read through some lot of times
but for that. I mean it
wasn't. And you come to. Yes.
You came straight to me is more
fun to take in this new me
and i don't think he had been here a
long time he came probably about 25
26.
If he'd like to write either
the eventual border out
that aunty island was here
and kind which made it a lot
easier because bees are the ones
that came after i had you know a lot easier
if you can call it a little because.
When i think of the first bananas
that we eventually have to perhaps
they would be was behind he had.
A cancer. Probably but there were books.
And his name in this name with the book.
So he had probably something behind it.
I think he had to do that.
I mean every time into the
writing that it had a thought.
And then i painted the bananas i need to
believe a little very quick and easy.
Others are an ellipsis if you play on when
we rebuild our house. The second time.
Uncle jack's feet win by the wind. I wouldn't
spit it out they clearly got the axe.
If you have prodded and knighted
fed by running like a good idea.
You know industries. Have
things like time you know.
But you need to he went on being
a boy he had a lot more liberty
and i did so he went to the apollo the
damn thing was quite a good game to move a
bit harder and even going straight
up stating things straight.
Chillin and with the riviera
which is damn near be.
The river a cop a man with that it
ain't home here so it was a game.
To me and i had the federal budget which i
think it's been too i went to the motel.
Anyway.
Yes the world is changing prices could
probably store also be able to drive the
host to other places today.
But of course i didn't.
I didn't do any of that and i
will know in the future on
that island damn thing i did about
came in and i would love to learn it.
But i knew that i wouldn't be alive.
And if my mother had heard about it
you know they've been mine for what.
I did didn't do it and the things
that you can do when you're young
and you really want to do that. Not to
lose your system. You still have to be me.
So when i got our older kids grow
up i didn't go out very much at all
when my kids were growing up you know
around i went to the tryst with the best of
them and.
The media hype of it
but never 90 years to get up there
were i had big sisters been offended.
Did live near her apartment which was
there any other relatives in australia
or about came out to australia a lot at
that time no light around
played around like a man
and his brother in law came out his brother
came out too liberal for a visit to me
and i came out to lead me to them and
i did the same. Things are time.
James in the know
and carried on the side of it he did he
have many of the family left in italy.
As he has a sister two sisters and brother
one of his sisters in the twin sister
and she the one cheating on as well. Yes.
And actually she's come to be to
business driving a car and she.
But that's about all the general these
people have to say you know after the war.
Things changed in italy. And.
Not exactly trying to write because a
lot of migrants came out just like the
italians but even 10 to 15 years
things changed for the better.
And when we went back in 78.
Everyone was really living well and
his brother had a lovely home.
Nima thinks possibly with all these people
leaving the gap ability answer the ones
that were left to make it a little.
So living at anything that one
standard time you went back.
And he was terrified that you can label.
Drop me in any street in my little
home town and i know where i am
and i kept telling him it's changing
it's changed he said i'm not where i am
and you're right i mean women
just couldn't believe it.
Big factories and sprang
up and there was nothing.
There was only one real place the good
still there and we went to visit them.
It was a mix of surviving.
Which wasn't very far from where i lived
and i still have our big kitchen where they
used to have a sealed room in the film
room and by have the stables and
i saw that because backside
or not i never seen my life in
that time we wouldn't believe
that she was it not been
a very emotional trip.
When you know whether it was for him
but it wasn't for me because i
didn't remember it but you know.
I didn't remember anything but it
was very bad news. Uncle. So yeah.
It would have been for him and also
strangely enough one of the things
that hit him most was that a lot of his age
had died really through. During a boy.
Like not a lot actually. During the
war years but later. You know 60 65.
My dad he's right.
He had very few make left when there
are younger you know and i don't know.
But it was a fact and they're
thinking it also changed kerry
and i couldn't really
relate to them at all.
Must be a driving me mad because
when you know every nationality
has their own mentality.
Mine was really i think the
big news was too and by
that time i guess we had a change.
It was it was where we were born
and you always have a certain sympathy for
a place where you know it wasn't home.
You know i know we had you know
which were very much a return.
Was not to be it really beautiful.
So if you have a good chance
you mean it is beautiful
and could you speak the dialect of
these families to spiteful dialect you
understand that you. And control you
and the way they are could
speak enough to get by.
You know living like the same dialect
very close in a few words very close.
Yes and cans weren't very far apart.
When you first met
and in the early days of you marriage
what did you speak may need hammering
that it was behind me tell you
and tell the children came
and really want to learn to
speak english so that then.
When you were speaking english
to them they were answering me.
Yes
but i suppose we tap into the current lie
ranging in english far better than years
went by by actually doing very little now
i must have to they can speak italian.
If i have to tell you i can't
but if i have too many real.
Yeah but i can understand it all i can
remember media here at home talking to ron.
In english.
You know trying to explain something to
them and he couldn't get the right word
but not quite in the tongue and.
And ron could understand it perfectly.
Yeah yeah. After the. The the landslide.
You have on that piece of mind
that you know originally wanted to be in
the house i read it in any yes we were
made for a good few years came and went
to school and we brought a little horse
and she used to ride to school
each horse being like grownups.
And when my brother in law came out
from a plane he thought i can ride
but horse of any little pony you know
we said look at all but we were off
and he said you gotta be kidding you know.
It's a lot but i don't get there
anything on the ships right off of him.
John ballard. So he got on
an after but five seconds
but they only went on these hope not that
that any evidence could
do anything with it.
She was a very good little ride and
we stayed there for a few years
but the bananas weren't very good position
which we are not in the beginning
that we couldn't get anything
else but we decided to try
and buy some land of our own because
it was still very hard to rent
and we boarded i found it with
100 like a fan. Trying it.
Craig between trying you
click on the channel.
And my husband and my brother
most to get there first and
that this time we didn't have
to shift the house goes.
It had a very large have been a very solid
team i had about would have been about
40 feet long and the boards were
right with us. And joining them.
It was a very very solid
and it had verandas all around which the
rain had the parish to be had to have a
very solid.
So we made that there and we
stole the original little house
and i think actually i think it got
shifted once again no and but it remained
and they are sentimental about that
and rely for the poor little thing
and been through much of the bible
but i did so with plan and some
bananas there was a few planted
when we bought the place
and we planted mormon on it being the two
we had to have a bigger a creature in the
nana's one sometimes that would cry
sometimes. And so we had planned.
Like i think it was quite literally
a good between us and that meant
that we had to plan. Was very rocky and.
On this path that we had eventually but.
My brother and my brother my brother in
law immediate fans and i had half each
and we planned it again on
this rocky part of the time.
And it does not really
a very good bananas.
To cover so rocky that we had to my
groom to plan for the nannies or
when the suckers came up and just an
ordinary cold i wasn't strong enough.
So libya had to use the actual drink.
And it come home and evander be a king and
that is to say i think i've got
cancer in me arms and if so that.
The spring cart accelerator case was on
our ride so it was very hard it was very
rocky.
When we used to have a horse a tiger
understand with a horse the slab first
but then we got a bit of money so we bought
a little caterpillar tractor which is
really a lie like the cracks like a
little caterpillar hannibal very small
and it was my job to drive
it to take the bananas in
and also help libya clear the land he would
have these big bushes of lantana he'd
crawl under and put a chain under it and
i drove it up so we cleared all this up
and paper all up. You know like.
Grass lane for the cattle
and one particular day i remember
i don't know what we were doing.
Probably pulling the antenna and i was
driving as usual and for some reason.
The cracks on the caterpillar
tractor pulled a stone out
and head on top of another stone with
children that was killed at the tractor
and it was on the side of a hill and
i could just see the trap and going.
And i heard they jump and of course i
jumped across the narrow can jump up hill.
So i jumped down hill. I jumped off but
thankfully. Thank god to check the storm.
Otherwise it would have
rolled on it couldn't miss
and not got any right you could open very
close then we had the pushing back by the
iron bar and got it off. It was very very
closely as though he thought he saw me.
Especially when he said jump and
i went down here well it wasn't.
But only right. Went on
and we kept on clearing i don't know probably
didn't die because of the got scared.
But anyway. Kept going and then
after we decided that we'd try
and get a dairy farm down there it.
Because the banana's are still too small
and we thought the pairing it
would be at an income strata rise
and i'm given a list take to come to a
month is back from a new plan to the tune
the 18 months
that the first budget the never very
big is a book so we would have planned
and beans in between with
that said gradually will be
that built up to hurt anyone
and we milked for about seven
right years and then at
that time we were still
with my brother in law
and my brother in law got an irate
loan them ripping down my hand to know
that we had a little bit machines which
you know yes we have a little bit machine
how many towns. We would have
making 70 or 80 some times.
What time is in mourning which is dialogue
that i think we do. We've got a bit.
I don't think we've got up in the
dark very much was usually dialogue.
And of course it was the sister in
law and i did the milking then not
and you know they were at the farm but
in between we still worked on the farm.
We had to chip in and get out the
house and chip on the grass comey
that chipping the grass
and the world who were in the spray at
all in those days of red have to chip.
But with a had a chip on the manana in
between the nana's with the high road which
looking back now. At the
wrong thing to do all
that we didn't have to scratch much in the
beginning because when you move that.
Topsoil next round. It
could get washed away.
Whereas if you spray the soil
would be wouldn't be useless.
So a lot of the topsoil would have been
washed right especially on the hill.
But of course we didn't know
that the time we didn't think
that within the milking and
i remember one morning.
To be looking machines had been playing up
and it broke the suction wouldn't.
Ok so they actually machines would
fall off if you put them on the couch
and it was a little plug.
Under a tube that way that would
have to be put in by hand.
And so this time it happened
and i thought i'll take that.
I have a twitch the machines are
and then when i get it right.
He tricked it on the glide.
But you never leave it but i
had put my arm fell away and
when it turned up on the real ramp forcibly
my arm was strong enough to stop the
real from spinning.
Otherwise it would have just thrown
my hand a bit in and i chatted up.
In the thought of coming to see me he did
shut it down just automatically so i
broke my arm and i had
but you broke your arm.
You have a broken both me and but it
only by one band you know on the side
but i have to have an
entire amount of course
that many difficulties of going to
because at the same time i have loved
and suffered from back like it is by the
way my brother in law who was there at the
time got shingles.
So he couldn't hear them talking
with my hand me my last one here
and i managed to i managed
to learn i was quite good.
Compare it with the one hand you
know and my sister and i carried on.
There were no children at this time.
Yes i tell you if i had
two children just didn't
but i had to guess who was born at
that at this stage but they had both
and i've got a children wrong.
But george you can get anyone in the
still no water and ron was born writer.
How many children altogether
i mean to and having to you.
I always wanted for you know i said.
But i don't think i could have coped not
right chad had a table ready to have it.
Probably lazy. To have never had times
when times and yes they were hard times.
Lots of outside work to do and i
mean if you didn't make a living.
You couldn't go on social
service like you do now.
You know you just carried
on like god no god
and i brought the children go to school
but i haven't started it but you go on and
and then she went on to george you
got to not george you've got to try
and you create him run went
to train your pre-school.
Yes
and then on the high school in the snow he
made money which me about yeah which me
really really the only high
school around in hard times.
Yeah about where they are but i got there.
Well i think that limit was
called believing in the ground.
It was called a high school
certificate in the correct meaning.
Yes the talk about how many years between
and nearly seven years right on the big
there's a big here i have a little problem
in between me.
But at night writing running because
that was a really little monetary.
Yes you know she was really really
good with him which helped me.
And where did i leave now challenging god.
The main down there for you
know the schoolteacher
that used to be trying to create
change married him and run. Right.
Rather we're very lucky with one is here
with us now because this energy left
school he went to sydney for four
years and when he was down there.
He got married when he was
down there and i got it went.
When danny wife went down
with him for about six
or eight months then i got a chance
but the boys he was working
for bought a shop in town
and said could they come back they could
come to work if they wanted to world you
couldn't keep a brick.
She rang a mother she rang everybody they
were coming back to leave my weekly.
Like please know that's why he came back.
Much of the class a rep sydney
pinkham team would like straight
kind of a shop as it was obvious
machine me going. Yeah that's what.
We come. He came back.
Otherwise we wouldn't have been paid because
now we've got the granddaughters you
know which is great for coming to handle
it. How many grandchildren all together.
And the same three girls you
never know and not have the boys
and ever anything else. And yes that
will be well now you have been told
and yes i have an intelligence
you know training.
She trained when we are going
to school just to teach
and i think i think it's good. I
don't know in the 20 big school.
I'm not sure i forget
names came in i think
and i teach at the school i went
to you know you go girl. I mean.
And you know i think everyone these coachable
school kids will be the big school
would have been at the school even then
it's a catholic school they work with
really the catholic school but then
i would say that more right hatred.
There was no way than now. You know.
Here and around them and even
understanding they say they you know.
Bring a hammer.
You know to rainier creek for about
17 years by then a children at school
where we decided to move into
town. The year was 1970.
But mikel coming in 100 started.
I really didn't like farm work i never
liked grammar but much actually.
But i try
and get a job in town which i did have
a balance factory which was then any i
but i think give them a call to.
The apparel so many i used
to work on means trousers.
I stayed there for about eight years which
helped us a lot because even though the
rain is wasn't very much
terrorist or money coming in
and returning after about three
months after we moved in libya
but really played up on him and he had to
have an operation on the discriminant.
And he couldn't for over a year.
So here i was with the bananas
to work a job at the factory.
I didn't really give me back the job
because we needed the money so i would be
working the bananas that
weekend we had more than jay
but if you had bought in shape.
So why don't they run gary
out from friday night
and cut the man on the
sideline pat them on the sun
and take the mean then leave
them here till the tuesday
when they would go right on the train
but i used to be a shame to drive the bananas
in the jeep with the banana kaiser i
thought public. Park at a fair right from
the factory many my lunch right over
and take them bananas and i like
them and then come home so i did
that for a long. Then
eventually my brother in law.
There's one day i remember
particularly well it was pouring rain.
And maybe had told me not to put logan 21
or 20 10 cases on the trial behind the
crawler tractor because it had missed it was
still heavy and i had about 30 cases.
It was trikes on the heart so i didn't want
to make a trip. So i loaded the moron.
And as i'm going down the hill.
Tractor slipped a little bit and one of
the tracks went out by using the garage
and it's done and done it before
then you get with a crowbar.
Just go backwards and
forwards until i went back in
but there i am on a fairly steep hill
30 cases of bananas on the trailer
and i think i said. God help
me. And i backed the tractor.
And it went in by itself
which you'd never.
I mean i had to do it
with a line behind it.
So i took the man who lives in the mine
not have to allow them onto the gate then
from me in coming to town
which went on for a would be.
The media heavy heavy.
Operation after that.
And i can remember i used to come
in every night to visit him.
Give me he was clean.
Could you come in the game saturday
night and i could have cried.
Because other side time
and i'd never been lower.
And i had a club that i don't need to
see sometimes have his team is good.
Sorry within parramatta.
And one day they have tractions on him
to try and give him but they don't
and they just couldn't do it
so i saw the doctor that time
and i think a lot could be david he
said be anything is an operation.
So we have the operation which did
read him but like much better after
that he couldn't bend over
for long but he could work.
He was just about all the time you ended
up getting a job in his machinery which he
wouldn't be a problem for
it over ten years and
that sort of we went on from may
have been an eventual i didn't work.
I actually wrote the year we decided to get
weebly to go back to italy can then we
went to bat then we both maybe would
write and we had a sound of time
when we came to with the time
wasn't sound for a bad father six
years i think when we sell the farm
and bought him an exact duplicate it.